The distance between the two points is the square root of 74. Great problem
solving if you found it. We'll start by drawing a rough sketch on the points on
the coordinate plane. If we want to find this distance between the two points,
we set up a right triangle in two dimensional space. The horizontal distance
goes from x equals negative 2 to x equals positive 3. So, we know that this
distance is a horizontal distance between the values of negative 2 and positive
3. Which is the total distance of 5 units. For this vertical distance we
want to find the difference between the y values or the change in them. We
start at y equals negative 3, and we climb all the way up to y equals 4. This
distance, so we know that this distance is 7 units. Keep in mind that the
distance on this vertical axis, or between the y coordinates, is the same out
here. This is a vertical distance that's the same as this one. So, we'll have
the change in x squared, which is 5 squared, plus the change in y squared,
which is 7 squared equals d squared, our hypotenuse. Squaring these numbers,
and finding this sum, will get 74 equals d squared. Now, we just take the
square root of both sides, keeping only the positive root. So, one d is equal
to the square root of 74. Now, if we try to simplify the square root of 74, we
notice that its factors are 2 and 37. These are not perfect squares, so we just
leave our answer as the square root of 74.